all right let's get to the phones at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 lots of people with much
to say today let's start with our caller
from the 408 area code who's calling
today from 408 hi David
yeah that's you hi David sue I'm a
staunch Democrat from California great
I'm going into the going into the 2020
election I have a concern that I've been
debating with my friends and I just
wanted to know your thoughts on it
sure what was not Zurn um you know I you
know I have some co-worker who are you
know Trump supporters and I'm concerned
about both the enthusiasm energy and
voter turnout of Democratic voter I know
that Hillary she had the same Democratic
voter
I mean demographic voters that Barack
Obama did is just not enough it was less
and speaking from personal experience I
have family members and friends who you
know they're not regular voters but they
did come out to vote for President Obama
though time yeah when it came to Hillary
they just weren't excited by her several
topics was gonna win anyway some of them
you know they just weren't as excited so
some of them didn't come out to vote for
her and I'm actually I'm concerned that
I'm will want a Democratic candidate
that could you know energize the voters
I'm not seeing that right now in the
field so I'm just wondering about your
thoughts well I think the issue is
bigger than the field right now I mean
III just I don't know that right now we
can say listen in all of the
head-to-head hypothetical matchups
basically every Democrat who has a shot
at winning the nomination is doing well
against Trump at the national level but
remember Hillary had more than enough
votes to defeat Trump at the national
level in the popular vote the problem
was because of 77,000 votes are 72,000
votes in three states
she lost the electoral college which of
course is what matters I mean we've got
an electoral college election I'm not
pretending like that doesn't matter so I
think that what you
every year we always hear similar
storylines whoever can get out the vote
is going to win this year the
Millennials and the young people people
who weren't old enough to vote last time
they're really gonna come out for X or Y
candidate and that will be the
difference-maker and in the end it's
like the trends are always the same
which is that the electoral college
favors Republicans over Democrats at a
systemic level that young people don't
end up really voting that much and the
most reliable voters are the older folks
who have been voting for a really long
time so I share with you the skepticism
about voter turnout but for me it's not
so much connected to any particular
candidate it's a much more general thing
I just think a lot of the enthusiasm
that started when Donald Trump was
elected and inaugurated has faded
partially because people have become
numb to the insanity partially because
of what's called scandal fatigue and
partially because of normalization so I
share your concerns but for me it's much
more overarching than about will Kamala
Harris versus Bernie versus Biden get
people to come out and vote um I know
right now a lot of the tentative
Democrats they're talking about policy
and such and that's sort of on an
intellectual level I know that a lot of
voters and a lot of people they vote
it's kind of a popularity contest they
both based upon their feelings how they
feel about a certain candidate you know
some of the Trump supporter they said
that you know they don't care about the
lies I don't care about all the scandals
what's important is the way the Trump
made his voter feel I Trump made his
voters feel that they are on the winning
team they're on Team America trying to
make America great again against these
enemies or these opponents that are like
fake news the immigrants etc you know
and I wonder about you know Barack Obama
he made people when they don't really
remember all his policies or what he
says but it made people feel hopeful for
a change he made them feel cool and
that's why they were excited you know
even my family members who don't
normally go they came down because
president Bach wrote Barack Obama he
made him feel great so right now I'm
worrying that we were talking so much
about intellectual things you know about
policies and such
I mean I'm wondering if the candidate
knows to focus on how to make beau to
feel you know positive and good and to
come out and vote super important I I
take issue with the idea that talking
about policy is like this
overintellectualizing esoterics thing I
think it is important but I think the
key is to mix the two things you're
saying I think candidates should be able
to talk about policy in a way that will
directly relate and connect emotionally
to the voter in a way that is important
to them very important points I really
appreciate the call and I hope to hear
from you again and I share the concern
about voter enthusiasm no question about
it